Hello and welcome to the video. This is a quick video on this new quad from Darwin FPV.
This is the CineApe 25. Now I've looked at a few other quads from Darwin FPV and I'm always
impressed because unlike some of the other people out there making these kind of ready-to-fly things,
the Darwin FPV stuff is a little bit less expensive. So it's kind of in the price range
of a lot more pilots but they do put a lot of thought and love into these things and this
25 is the latest one. So I thought I'd get it in and we'll have a go. Now this is available in a
couple of different versions. It comes with Walksnail and I've got the analog version here.
So it's been a while since I've reviewed an analog quad but lots of you pilots out there I know
are still flying analog. Other 60% of all my viewers last time we did a poll are still flying analog and
waiting for digital HD and maybe making a choice in the spring. So let me unbox this and go through
the specs, talk about some of the cool stuff. Let's give it a fly and see what it's like.
So the big thing with this is this is like that kind of big whoop style where it has a high strength
one-piece injection molded prop guard. Very useful because it means that you can bounce off stuff.
I've been very happy flying much closer into obstacles with this knowing that if I hit something
it's just going to bounce off it rather than destroy a prop potentially snap an arm. Battery life claimed
on this is up to nine minutes. We'll see what that is in a moment. I think nine minutes is optimistic,
gentle flying potentially without any kind of action camera installed. So again this is the Darwin FPV
Cine Ape 25. It's an X style layout. Six bladed props. Wheelbase is 112 millimeters. Dimensions of this
thing isn't particularly big. It's a nice size for flying around large indoor environments and also
flying outside as well. So it's about 160 by 160 by 43 millimeters. Flight controller on this is an F411
base thing and it does have 30 amp 3 to 4S ESCs. I'm running mine on 4S here. Again as I said in the
introduction this happens to be the analog version. Comes with a Caddx ant. Not a fan of the ant
unfortunately but we'll see how it performs here in a moment with a 600 milliwatt analog VTX. But
incitingly there is also a HD version which is the Caddx walk snail one which comes with the Avatar
Mini 1S that I looked at recently which is a nice unit and I'm tempted maybe to put my one of those
in here. Motors are 1504 3600 kV and those propellers are HQ prop T63 MMX6 propellers. Recommended
battery for this is an 850 milliamp power 4S pack. They reckon you'll get about nine minutes hovering
time. Realistically I think you're going to get a little bit less and I'll talk about what I got.
I'm using a slightly smaller battery to make it a little bit more nimble. I'm using a 650 milliamp
power battery rather than the recommended 850. So let's have a very quick look at the configuration.
Now I can plug it into the computer. Again diff and dump going to be down below. So let's first of all
plug the thing in and turn on expert mode. Have a quick look at the tabs. Ports are configured for
this so the only thing we have is the serial receiver. I've got mine running on SBUS which is
how it comes by default. Mine didn't come with a receiver and we've also got smart audio for the VTX as
well. Configuration 8k gyro 4k pid loop frequencies. CPU load is pretty high running about 52% there at
the bottom but then it's an F4 base flight controller. This is how it's set up. Pretty standard stuff here.
Power and battery is set like this. Seems to work okay. Failsafe is set to drop which is what you want.
Pid tuning as you'll see in a moment from the flying is very relaxed and gentle but for a kind
of a filming mini quad like this that's exactly what you want. Although you can get quite a turn
of speed out of this thing it can hoop around when you need to. Receiver again set for SBUS by default.
This is how it comes. You could also set it up for other stuff as well but the little cable that comes
on it is kind of designed to be plugged or soldered onto an SBUS receiver. Modes are set like this. I
would definitely come in here and play with the modes. This is a slightly unusual way to do it.
Basically auxiliary one arms it and puts it into angle so they're not expecting you to use horizon
even though you can flip and roll. On-screen display looks like this. I'd definitely come in here and move
things around. Everyone has their own particular way of doing it. Video transmitter for my analog version
here is all set up and the tables all loaded. It's pretty much ready to rock and roll. Again dump and
diff are down below if you want to go and have a look. In terms of flying. Flying is an awful lot of fun.
The noise level from those multi-related props is a little bit higher than I would like. It's very very
kind of a high wind buzz which does mean that even when it's a reasonable distance away from you
you can still hear it and if you blip the throttle then everyone in the field that you're in is going to hear it as well.
But it does give it quite a little bit of punch. Hovering at below 50% throttle and I'm getting about
four and a half minutes out of a 650 milliamp hour pack without an action camera. I'm getting just under
four minutes with an action camera. Something like a peanut or something like the Runcam Thumb Pro on the nose.
Obviously you're going to get a little bit more flight time if you use that 850 milliamp hour pack
that's recommended. Tune is nice and gentle as we've already looked at and it does have the ability
for crisp rolls and flips if you really want to. I don't think that's what it's designed for but it
does show you how nimble it can be if you want to fly it in horizon or rate mode to get some more
aggressive filming in tighter spaces where those protected props are going to come in handy.
The one thing that's letting it down is unfortunately the image from that Caddx Ant.
I kind of already alluded to this but I'm not a fan of the Caddx Ant. I don't think it's a particularly
good camera. I don't think that it does a great job and it's performing in exactly the same way here
on this model. So for me if I was getting one of these I would probably swap that out with something
else or ideally I think the walks now version of this would be my preferred version and it's going to
be a little bit more expensive but walks now in that 1S kit is going to give you a much nicer view
and allow you to fly very close to and around stuff while still being able to see it clearly.
You can see here that even though I'm flying around the goal posts I'm not really getting a clear view
until I'm pretty close and if I'm moving at speed I'm already going to hit it before I can correct and
get out of the way. There is also a little bit of noise from the VTX here and there is a cap
fitted already so they have obviously tried to sort that out but there is a little bit of
interruption and problem with noise. So there's a lot of things that I like here. I like the size,
I like the design, I like the optional foam bumper strip that can go around the outside that comes in
the box. That means if you are flying it indoors and you bump into stuff not only you're not going to
damage the quad you're also not going to damage the thing you've bumped into. Easy to get this under
250 grams if that's important to you. With my 650 gram battery and the model itself I'm getting under
250. Now in lots of places as soon as you add a camera the whole 250 limit kind of becomes a moot
point but if that's important to you it's good to know that you can. There is obviously a room for a
small action camera at the front. Again it's not a massive amount of room and it doesn't have a huge
carrying capacity so Runcam Thumb Pro or something like Yucadex Peanut would be my go-tos for this.
Also quite a fan of the fact that they're not asking ridiculous money for this. The price of
everything has gone up thanks to all the issues that we've had over the past two or three years
and it does mean that more pilots can afford to get their hands on a nicely built well put together
model like this. I do like the fact that they've also made the frame very easy to take apart
just with one hex driver you can kind of take out a handful of screws and the whole kind of middle
tower drops out which gives you access to everything if you want to play around.
But even though the onboard USB connector for the flight controller is hidden away inside the model
you don't have to take it apart in order to plug it in. They're very cleverly thought of that and
there is a USB-C connector hidden away here at the front of the model underneath where you would
mount an action cam. Just peel back the rubber grommet and you can plug it into your computer and do the
configuration from here. That's a really smart design decision. So there's only a couple of
things to be aware of with this. First of all I'm not a fan of the FPV performance in this analog setup.
The HD FPV option would be my choice or potentially replacing that Caddx ant with something else.
It is wired for SBUS by default and lots of pilots will want to put CRSF on there so maybe that should
be a consideration for Darwin FPV when they're building these things in future give you that
option. It has a linear antenna at the back so be aware of that. Ideally what you want are linear
antennas on your goggles. I think for the extra weight I'd personally preferred some form of very
small lollipop style circular polarized. And those six blades do make for quite a high whine and quite an
inefficient creation of thrust. It does keep the model nice and small but it does mean that you get
shorter flight times and there is that extra little bit of noise as you're flying around. And the other
thing of course is that unfortunately although Darwin FPV are obviously working very hard to keep the price
within the range of most pilots because the price of the components going up the price of this stuff
is as well. So in summary this is a very nice little quad. This is a great option if you want to have
something that you can fly around outside, fly around indoors. The setup's really nice. The only
thing that's letting this down is the performance of that FPV setup. Thank you for spending your time
today watching that video. You can find me in all the usual places on social media and if you're trying
to learn about a subject then check out the playlist. All of my videos are organized into easy to follow
playlists that if you're trying to learn a topic will take you from the basics right the way through to
some pretty advanced stuff.